white guys regular old white guys are
considered the scum of the earth this is
a public view now there's a tick tock
just went viral of an Asian woman
explaining how much she doesn't like
white people
hi there you must be new to my account
I say what what to remind
[Music]
because in order for True equality to
happen or Supremacy has to be dismantled
and a lot of people are not even aware
of their use of whiteness unless someone
like me points It Out by calling it
in your case you as a oink woman telling
an Asian woman how to speak on her
account is a pretty privileged mindset
because I would have never thought to go
to your account and say hey your face is
really annoying you should change your
profile photo I would never say that to
you like that would have never crossed
my mind like who am I to tell you that
and you should have awareness of your
actions you as a woman telling me how to
speak is tone policing and that's a
behavior that's very common among women
you may have not intended that but there
are many women who act exactly like you
so that's why I say what to raise your
awareness because it's so ingrained in
you you may not realize it and maybe
next time when you're about to do the
very same thing my annoying what will
ring in your ear and stop you
so you're welcome
this is just a crazy woman right this is
just a crazy Fringe woman
actually this is the public opinion of
the New York Times The Washington Post
the whole establishment media the
universities the entertainment culture
and the government
white people are bad
what she's saying white she's she's
making a sound as though she's pulling
up phlegm to spit that's why she's
pronouncing it that way
as as if to say white people are they're
worse than spit they deserve to be spit
upon
that is not just some angry bigoted
lady's opinion that is what is being
taught in schools what's being taught in
schools is that whiteness is
intrinsically evil and needs to be
abolished there are calls to abolish
whiteness in major newspapers and
magazines
it's not just this crazy lady in fact
rather than this crazy lady changing the
culture to hate white people I suspect
it was in the other direction I suspect
the culture which constantly reinforces
the idea that whiteness is bad and white
people should be ashamed of themselves
and and white privilege and white Ness I
guess is something to be abolished very
likely that cultural view which long
predates that woman
helped to form her views
this is the view on the admissions
committees this is the view in hiring
practices this is the view of the
government which is dedicating resources
and energy toward dismantling whiteness
and all the rest of it this is
your country do not write that crazy
lady off it's it's just like the Jeffree
Star video
you you think that we're living in the
same culture that we've been living in
your whole life but that Overton window
of acceptable political dialogue has
moved so radically far to the left that
now we're in the place we're saying hey
white people aren't
the absolute devil
is a somewhat controversial opinion I
don't know that you're allowed to voice
that
at work in the government or in your
schools speaking of white privilege
we turn our attention again to East
Palestine Ohio
where we are told the water is totally
fine the air is clean again
even just a couple of weeks after this
big massive chemical smell the water is
totally safe to drink except
Water Utilities in Cincinnati and
Northern Kentucky have decided to shut
down their water intake after the spill
this would be the Greater Cincinnati
Water Works and Northern Kentucky water
district they're just going to take some
precautions why just just in case no
because they tested the water and they
found low levels of chemicals from the
toxic spill
in some places had intakes along the
Waterway and they're seeing reports of
fish dying on mass in the local
waterways and they're seeing the East
Palestine residents who are getting
headaches who are developing rashes
because the town has been poisoned
so you're saying well look we just we've
got some low levels of these chemicals
being found so we're going to shut down
the water intake well they can't be that
low if you're going to shut down the
water intake at two of these Utilities
in two different states that seems like
a pretty big problem that everybody is
trying to downplay
I am seeing news of this story reported
in very very few places and the and the
politicians are all trying to downplay
it notice they won't go there Joe Biden
isn't going to East Palestine
there may eventually be enough political
pressure that he has to go you're not
seeing people to judge show up to East
Palestine
you're not seeing the Ohio senator
say that he will drink the water from
East Palestine
I want to ask you would you drink the
water in East Palestine
officials there who are saying it's safe
they
they show the residents that they they
would drink it
well I think they are I mean I talked to
the mayor the mayor said definitively
emphatically that people can drink the
water the Mayors I don't know if I don't
think the mayor has small kids he looks
a little older to me I didn't ask him
but about bathing his kids but he would
he has said he would drink this water
right but to show the residents who are
so skeptical do you think that they well
I think he probably is
yeah I think he probably is
um but I I do think though as I said
when when you know you hear all this
stuff about stock BuyBacks and they're
under investing as you say and in rail
safety the the tracks themselves and the
cars
do you think these Democrat politicians
who are saying the water safety you
think that you know you guys should all
drink the water
well yeah I think they are
well hold on sir you are one of the
politicians you are the Democrat senator
from Ohio you're trying to convince
everybody the water is safe so would you
drink the water and would the local
politicians the mayor of East Palestine
and all the rest would they drink the
water too yeah yeah no I'm pretty sure
they are bro it's a very simple question
will you drink the water
the answer is no
obviously Democrat Sharon Brown is not
going to take one sip of that water now
the other senator from Ohio JD Vance
who's the Republican he was asked this
question and he said no I wouldn't drink
the water I would drink bottled water
which fortunately for right now is still
being given out for free in the
community but I would not drink the
water because it's poisoned
Sharon Brown doesn't want to admit that
it's poisoned there's no no I think they
are I think let's move on let's talk
about something else I want to talk
about I don't know gun control or
something anything other than talking
about this major environmental disaster
it's amazing that the Democrats they
only ever want to talk about the
environment they only ever want to talk
about climate everything is related to
climate covid was caused by climate
change food shortages caused by climate
change migration caused by climate
change we've got to save the environment
except when there's a gigantic toxic
chemical spill and then
Move Along Move Along nothing to see
here
that doesn't it doesn't make a lot of
sense to me
if the libs care about the environment
which which they don't really and if the
libs care about small town America which
they don't they hate small town America
so if you want to talk about white
privilege I think I think the white
population of East Palestine East
Palestine Ohio is like 90 or something
so we'll write that off that's that's
those rural people those hillbillies
flyover bitter Clinger
get cling to their guns and religion
let small town America die that's what
you're hearing and you're hearing it
from even the politicians the rest of
the show continues now you do not want
to miss it you can go to dailywear.com
for two months free on all annual plans
we'll see you over there
[Music]
foreign